[Music]
in
English
[Music]
d
the
parties eat
until the end that has more spirit to
work
that catalog is that it has the billboard
to tremble
[Music]
chimborazo fall asleep volcano in ecuador
is javier from mount everest and surf
with ten full
of traditional parts would have is in that
region say with hispanics of the
colonial entity times the wizard and night and
people to try of aes had your mega
sport in your ass of turing at a level that
allows 3
[Music]
today since I get up
we worked before quite familiar
we were sharing with mom with german
kill
twenty three years the go to steal from
mini people urine for the video of hui
ling from has been lowlands now baltasar
is from the guandique hospital maternal
or day by day world factors
then argentinista work and  conclusion
ice is unique ice of
general damage it tastes like ice
tablet of emulation of its own it
tastes like mint and pretty it
is good for all for boys
this  Pop ice is I like it
[Music]
I don't say the work
in an unequal battle
santimb ribéry thick in washington of
bronze in the place all physical walker of
the altitude
of metal butters work the same the hardest
word without having this law
[Music]
we already know of the morning a road a
slope for honor
[Music]
to return to the wood also the pain
when we arrive in January at the time of
oil
they cover themselves with want to do trying
we do what we don't credit square with
pick
the sky  the endings are heavy it's as
heavy as dirt we
wrap it with little legs to bring it closer to the
ticket
the dead man with a package let's not leave much
because you get a little bit of this work but
downstairs work towers
once we have an accident we advance
to any 10 is what big blows
Courage passes any day against
land broke
[Music
] I don't care less this symbol doesn't give me money
to my
farming friend the many other fader
chimborazo well leave the v  olcán a
shield know and navolato regarding in the
last
[Music]
it is still quite cold quite
quite cold there was before it is not a very
pleasant memory nobody fulfilled it a little
there is not now but as the weather
changed and javi with worman
church servicing dereito tuenti twitter
and get involved  yesterday and they conditioned the same in
the very large world pride and there be
Guatemalan rock day is 2 rock blues
and roll down I am Adrián Ianiero
balances is that wolder war iii forum
baltasar the computers that are and with
this I am really selling myself knocking down
market
before a week  and r we went a week
five days
now a week two days twice there is no
market that we have our own chair
[Music]
each batch of my father in color began
has in the athletes you do not pay anything else
in cadiz in you are for preschool a
gogó the food of  planting with my ice I
study as a bullet for beto by net
meta you
[Music]
against the ice of chimborazo more or
less about 55 years more
[Música  sica]
is a Riobambeña tradition it is the only one
in Ecuador because purple is
ours I don't feel very proud to
work with baltasar God give me
health and life I will continue buying ice
and
[Music]
I am happy very badly yesterday was
clearly
for  I'm
30 and I know God
after their work
[Music]
until they feel like
working
for money